الولايات المتحده تفرض عقوبات على اعضاء
ومنتسبين للحرس الثوري الايراني وفيلق
القدس التابع له واشنطن تقول ان العقوبات
تشمل من شاركوا في سلسله مؤامرات
واغتيالات استهدفت مسؤولين سابقين في
الحكومه الامريكيه ومواطنين امريكيين
ايرانيين ومعارضين ايرانيين وثائق مسربه
كشفت ان ايران تسلح الميليشيات في سوريا
لمرحله جديده من الهجمات ضد القوات
الامريكيه بحسب مسؤولين استخباراتيين وفق
صحيفه واشنطن بوست الوثائق تصف جهودا
جديده واوسع نطاقا من جانب موسكو ودمشق
وطهران لطرد الولايات المتحده من سوريا ما
قد يسمح للرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
باستعاده المحافظات الشرقيه التي يسيطر
عليها الاكراد المدعومون من واشنطن الان
الوثائق المسربه تصف ايضا خططا لحمله
واسعه النطاق من قبل معارضي الولايات
المتحده من شانها ان تشمل تاجيج المقاومه
الشعبيه ودعم حركه شعبيه لتنفيذ هجمات ضد
الامريكيين شرقيه وشمال شرقي سوريا عبر
مركز تنسيق لتوجيه الحمله
الوثائق لا تضم ما يشير الى تورط روسي
مباشر في التخطيط لحمله التفجير لكنها
تبين دورا اكثر نشاطا من جانب موسكو ضد
الولايات المتحده بلال البجداني العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات